so um so the main question that sort of
motivates this
is is how we can characterize
experimental systems with with high
confidence
um and hopefully get this
working okay so so
um if we're trying to understand Quantum
systems there sort of this obvious
problem as said that these systems are
exponentially complex to describe and
furthermore we only only have access to
them um classically we're essentially
classical devices
ourselves um right we we we only we only
see a few measurements of of this
exponentially complex Quantum
State uh but there's there's also sort
of more subtle problem so for example
say we want to prepare a random bit a
natural approach might be just to
prepare um K plus so that's a state k0
plus K 1 a uniform superposition and
then measure it right that should give
you half zero proba one half one but you
know in practice isn't this isn't maybe
the best way of of doing it because
there could be all sorts of problems so
like an obvious problem that You'
definitely worry about is it might be
slightly biased so instead of exactly
one/ < tk2 0 one overun one it could be
slightly off from one overun two so you
get probabilties slightly off from 1
half
one2 um but you might also worry about
slightly more subtle problems in your
experimental system for example um maybe
uh something about it results in there
being correlations between um first time
you you extract a random bit and the
second time or between the first time
and the last
time and so you you you'd want to worry
about these kinds of problems as well
and uh sort of going in much much
further you might you might even worry
about completely crazy problems like it
could be that this this Quantum device
it's not really um preparing kep plus
and measuring it like like you like it's
actually just it has pre-programmed
inside it a classical random string and
when you ask for random bit it just
gives you a bit of that random string um
and that's a problem because this random
string could be shared with the
environment or shared with your attacker
in
advance so I mean maybe that's just
paranoid maybe that's maybe that's a
crazy error model to worry about but I
think the point is um in in a in a
realistic setting you have to draw the
line somewhere and it's not clear where
you should draw the line from from the
left to the right uh it's not clear what
the CR what the right definition of
security should where it should where it
should lie and so for us we're just
going to assume that we're all the way
on the right hand side that that we're
completely paranoid and we really are
worried about the case where the device
was made by the adversary in
fact and then so here sort of the
security model we're not going to try to
understand what's going on inside this
well we're not going to make assumptions
about what's what's going on inside the
system we're going to try to um
characterize it uh under under worst
case assumptions um it's just some
blackbox Quantum device and we'll even
allow it to be made by the
adversary um
so so now we'd like we'd like to
generate a random bit using this
blackbox device and that's impossible
because it does have this problem that
it could have the the random string
could have been pre-programmed but as um
said it does suddenly become possible
once you have two devices that are
separated from each other and cannot
communicate with each
other and so this is where we introduce
this this CHS AG game so um and I I'll
formulate it as as a
game uh so so here I I have two devices
I'm calling Alice and Bob and then Eve
is me Ben uh whatever uh so so so so the
game works works like this we we we
choose these random bits A and B uh we
we we send a to Alice B to Bob and we
get back X and Y and the question is uh
is the xor of the two responses equal to
the product A and B A *
B and so for example if these are
classical devices they can win with
probably 34s they can just output xal
yal 0
so the x is equal to zero and three out
of the four questions that's equal to
the product except if AAL Bal
1 um quantumly you can do better so so
so
here's a different way of showing the
same thing which did for for um uh for
the optimal strategy quantumly so so
here we assume that uh here here they
they have an epr
pair um Alice depending on the question
she makes one of two two outcome
measurements so on the left she's
measuring in the uh uh both in the XZ
plane of the block sphere and the left
she's measuring in this direction of if
she gets question zero or in this
direction if she gets question one and
Bob is measuring either along the x-axis
on question zero or on question one and
along the red axis the z- axis if um his
question is zero you can see that uh if
if they both if they both get zero the
the angle between these axes is is 45
degre if one gets zero and the other
gets one the angle between the the axes
is
45° uh but if if they both get one the
angles between the axes are
135° which means that they're going to
Output the same answer uh with probably
cosine squ pi over 8 if if they both get
zero or or one gets one but if they both
get one then they get the different
answers with probably cosine squ pi over
8 which and that's exactly the
correlations that we'd like in this in
the chsh game and so that's how um
that's how Quantum devices can win this
game with probity cosine squ pi8 which
is roughly 85% slightly it's 10% better
than the best classical
strategy and so this lets us um test the
system is quantum mechanical um but we
want we want to go much
further
so so let me State the first rigidity
theorem so so here uh we we assume that
these two devices share in arbitrary
Quantum state in arbitrary density
Matrix um and they have arbitrary h
spaces ha and HB um which could be
infinite dimensional they're not cubits
or anything
necessarily uh and they can make
arbitrary projective measurements on the
on these states to determine their
outcomes and then the theorem we show is
that if if they win this game with
probably at least roughly cosine squ Pi
8 so cosine squ Pi 8us Epsilon then up
to a local basis change up to local
isometry is a separate isometry in each
half the initial state is root Epsilon
close to the ideal state
the epr pair possibly intenser product
with some other junk uh and furthermore
uh their measurements are root Epsilon
close to the ideal measurements and the
way you can qu quantify that is is is
you I mean we don't actually know what
their measurements are what the
um I mean they could be doing anything
on areas of the Hilbert space on which
the state has no support uh and so the
way we quantify this is is we just say
the effect of their measurements is the
same as the effect of the adal
measurements um up to square of Epsilon
error
again so this is this is the kind of
theorem um which says that one once we
characterize the probability of winning
we can we can characterize the strategy
um and this is simple to prove I I'll
skip the proof it's it's it's sort of um
it's it's it's almost an immediate
exercise you just have to
um look at look at the projective
measurements that they make so that
gives you two hyperplanes and now look
at the dihedral angles between these two
hyperplanes and that gives you the cub
and therefore you can grind through some
algebra um but I I want to say more
about the the bger theorem actually in a
minute all right so so how do we use
this theorem basically we just apply
simple statistical tests so what you're
going to do is you're going to apply
you're going to run this game a million
times for example um and you're going to
see H how many games did they win and
the point is certainly classical devices
could win 85% of the games it's just
exponentially unlikely right they they'd
have to get extremely lucky um and so we
can show instead of if they win like all
right so I'm kind calling it omega star
from now on um so that's 85% or cosine
squ Pi
8 if they have a high probabil high
probability of winning close to the
optimal fraction of games uh then that
means that at the start of a random game
in the middle there um when that game
began they had to have had a high
probability of winning that one game
just by statistics there's nothing
quantum here and therefore apply the
previous theorem they have a high
probability of winning this one game um
therefore by the previous theorem they
had to be using an epr pair in that one
game or Square of Epsilon close to an
epr
pair and so that that says that that so
so the Assumption here is that uh
they've won 85% of a million games and
the conclusion is that they have one APR
pair in a random
game so uh I mean it's interesting I
guess it's says that they're quantum
mechanical uh and they have at least one
bit of entanglement but it's it's rather
a pretty disappointing theorem I think
um yeah you said it says they're quantum
mechanical but you're assuming they're
quantum mechanical to do the analysis uh
I'm I'm assuming they're quantum
mechanical it says that they're not
classical sorry that's what I
meant so really we like we'd like much
more sophisticated tests we'd like to be
able to say that if you play a bunch of
games and if you pass all these tests
then not only do you share one bit of
entanglement but you share a l lots of
entanglement and that would be something
that we could actually leverage and use
to um use to prove more theorems and and
so here's sort of the main
theorem uh in a in a reasonably
quantitative way so so the setup is is
going to be I'm going to play little end
games at a time just in sequence one
after the next and then I'm playing
capital N blocks of these games uh with
the two
devices and this okay so so the
Assumption of the theorem says it's the
same as before if there's a high
probability that they win close close to
the optimal fraction of games close to
85% of the
games then when you look at a random one
of these blocks of little L games at the
beginning of that block they had to have
little end epr
Pairs and during that block when they
played that block they had to be
measuring them those epr pairs one at a
time uh according to the ideal strategy
so winning them with probably cosine squ
pi/ 8 with these with these
measurements
Canal sorry everything's sequential I
just broke it up in in this way
yeah um so so this kind of theorem
really really does give us way just of
giving a statistical test of seeing that
um they do share lots of entanglement at
least little on little on epr pairs
worth of entanglement based on a
statistical
test um it's kind of inefficient so to
make this serum work we need capital N
to be polinomial and little n so in in
theory it's efficient um but it's not a
great polinomial I don't think uh and
second um uh I I didn't say how close
this is here and again that'll be
polinomial in
epsilon um but it'll be like Epsilon to
the 1/ C for some constant C and C is
like something quite impractical um Ben
can you say again how this theorem
improves over the last one is it that
with this one like even after the test
is over you still know that there's lots
of entanglement in the other blocks
or
um no I mean in both of these tests or
in both of these theorems um there's
sort of retro retrospective the way the
way I'm describing it in that because by
by the time you get this
conclusion um you've played all the
games you've destroyed all the intang
all right so so no the the the the
interesting thing of this theorem really
really is that uh it gives you a way of
guaranteeing that you have n Bits of
entanglement at the same time oh okay
rather than just one which is I mean
it's very intuitive you you think in the
previous serum you would too but all
right this is just saying that good yeah
yeah just for me to understand this
retroactively what formally means does
it mean that uh if you don't have this
many entanglement bits in the very
beginning of the whole experiment then
your probability of succeeding in the
experiment is very low is that actually
what is being proven
um well that's certainly true and that
that's that's a coral are of this but I
think I think this is but the thing is
that I don't see a definition of this
because after something has I mean
classically you can make a history of
what happened but quantumly if you run
some experiment you can actually not
really necessarily say what was true at
an earlier point because you can't copy
that information to look at it later I
mean it's not necessarily well- defined
statement to say um earlier in this
execution there was this much
entanglement because if later I make a
measurement it's changed what I mean the
quantum state is gone I see
no I think I think it's perfectly fine
to say that um because it was there so
so so
uh maybe maybe the Assumption isn't
clear so I'm not saying if if you win
85% of the games I'm saying that it's
not clear imagine this game that I have
um two cubits yeah um in like just un
in the beginning then I run a process in
theend end I measure whether these
cubits are in the uh I measure them in
the Bell basis okay and I get some
outcome and then they are suddenly
entangled and actually in a sense uh
like this entanglement uh so I'm
measuring that they were always
entangled because they were in the
beginning in a superposition of
different possibilities how they were
entangled so it's not really clear
whether it's operation here no I'm just
talking about the fact that it's not
well defined at least for me what it
means that something was
true um when we have measured and
therefore destroyed the information of
what was actually the case
earlier uh well I I I think it is I
think it is okay to say that at a
particular time in the protocol there
was entanglement even if later on it's
gone or or it's created later on or
something crazy happens later on I'm
saying if if you if you interrupted the
protocol after at a after a random you
know at a Rand at the beginning of a
random block if you stopped the protocol
there and looked at whatever the quantum
state is there is some Quantum State at
that point then if you're interruped you
don't know the right that's right I
agree no that's a problem
right experiment you're just saying that
about the possible State exactly but the
state is already gone at the point he
tell talks about it that's fine no
that's not fine well it might be fine
information it's physically not
meaningful what the state was if we
don't measure it but I mean if you look
at the statement of the theorem there's
an if and a then right and so the if is
a probability of what will happen if you
make all these measurements and that can
be that statement is well defined even
at the beginning of the protocol yes
right and so the so so if you think of
this as a statement then at the
beginning of the protocol
that in the future when once these
measurements are made here's a statement
about the probability of the outcome
right then then is well defined at that
point
and everything's fine yeah but that's
not the thing we were talking about I
think it was further
below I think you should think in the
counter say that it was
not well the problem the thing I then
with high probability you would get
something
else um if you like and it burns you can
say that it was a good match even though
after it
burn right thank
you
um let me move on a little bit um so so
so so I I I like Daniel's interpretation
of this that's a good way of putting it
um uh you have you have to say how do
you establish this this initial
assumption and maybe that's not clear
you're going have to think about how how
you get that assumption in the first
place um but but anyway let me just say
a little bit more about what this means
formally so uh the formally the way we
express this kind of theorem and that's
half the work in proving lots of these
theorems is just stating them carefully
is um we we express it all in terms of
uh super operators so um and and Trace
distance so what what I mean is say you
have a two outcome projective
measurement so you're you're making uh
measurement with these projections pi
and Pi complement that that corresponds
to the following super
operator where it takes a state row IT
projects it by pi and it say that's
outcome zero it adds a classical
register in zero and then it projects
the same state into a i complement and
add say a classical register one so this
is super operator that describes uh the
measurement Pi 1 minus
pi and so for us we have this uh super
operator here that that EA
hat that that describes the ideal chsh
game and so in the deal CHS game with
probably one half you you input coin
zero so that's his first register and
then you make some projective
measurement Alice make some projective
measurement some ideal projective
measurement and then then there's some
outcome that's that's that corresponds
to the uh
measurement and so this this is the the
ideal super operator for which I'll I'll
have this hat notation but of course she
can have sort of an arbitrary super
super operator um and so the conclusion
of this theorem that says that uh the
the two devices strategy is close to the
ideal strategy what it really means is
that up to these isometries uh that that
embed their hilber spaces into um uh a
tensor product of of of n cubits with
with another Hilbert space
uh their actual super operator
here for the two parties for for the
first say J
games um is is almost applied to the
initial State row is has almost the same
is almost the same as the ideal super
operator applied to um epr pairs in
Trace distance this should this should
be true for every J from 1 to
n that's that's what the conclusion of
the theorem really says
okay so that's a little bit technical
but I just want to make it slightly more
precise
too all right so
um how do we prove this kind of theorem
uh it really has four steps uh the first
step um is is a is a bit of statistic so
just classical statistics or Martin
gilin kind of things um so first of all
we say that uh basically if you if you
have a probability close to one of
winning a about 85% of the games then in
a random block of games it must be the
case that you win every single one of
those games with probably
85% um that's false but you you wi every
single one of those games with probably
85% most of the
time so so for most of the for most of
the previous games you're going to win
the the current game with probably 85%
which means I can probably apply the the
uh the single shot uh chsh game rigidity
theorem and so therefore this this says
that in a random block of end games uh
we're going to um uh every single game
is being one with probably about Omega
Omega minus omega star minus Epsilon and
so we we have cubits and here already
just just to get the statistics working
we've already lost like a quadratic
Factor um so little and to get this
working we need to expand the system by
expand the number of games quadratically
just for just by statis
ICS okay um all right so now we have
these cubits uh but but they um sort of
they're all messed up like they they
overlap each other potentially uh the
cubits you're measuring in different
games and there's some history
dependence potentially like the Cubit
you measure in game two could be either
of these two red cubits maybe like
depending on the outcome of game one
actually there's four outcomes of game
one so there's four I should have drawn
four of them uh the key you used in game
three depend could the the location of
the Cubit you measure in game three
could depend on the outcomes of the
first two games so again it there there
could be lots of different
ones and and the more the most
interesting step of the proof is is
actually showing that these cubits don't
overlap each other at all intuitively so
so uh so actually that they that they
lie in tensor product with each other
they're
independent but there're still history
dependence and then the last step of the
proof uh sort of glues these different
transcripts together to show that um
there's no history
dependence so so you you measure the
Cubit this this black Cubit for game one
you measure the red cubit in game two
independent of what the result of game
one was and then in game three you
measure the blue Cubit independent of
the previous
results so let me say something of the
the most interesting step which is how
we how we how we determine a tensor
product structure in this big infinite
dimensional completely a morph Silber
space and let me first say a little bit
about what could potentially go wrong
than what we worry about when you you
try to come up with these these kinds of
arguments and
um maybe one thing you worry about is is
whether these pictures are accurate
which which they're not really but let
me just try to um try to show so draw
some pictures anyway to hopefully give
some
intuition so say we play the first games
the first seven games on these cubits
that they use they overlap slightly like
they they can overlap by like square of
Epsilon at least because they're not
exactly an erpr which which which would
be monogamous they're only close to epr
pairs which are not exactly
monogamous uh and but then the problem
is that the errors these square of
Epsilon errors could keep on
accumulating and maybe in the last game
or game eight whatever uh there's
suddenly uh a huge overlap so the
location of the Cubit you measure in
game eight could overlap completely with
the location of the Cubit that you
measured in game one and then you would
not have this then this theorem would be
false because uh the theorem says that
everything is in tensor
product
and so we need to um show that actually
errors do not accumulate that's that's
one thing that we want to show and this
isn't this isn't so easy I mean uh
because it seems like they can so for
for example here I I have five cubits um
five say say I start with five epr pairs
and in the first one you measure mostly
the first the first Cub except you have
square root of Epsilon eror on the last
Cubit on the second one you measure
mostly this blue Cubit except you have
square of Epsilon error on this last
cuit and so on and so it doesn't take
too many rounds before you get a ton of
air accumulated on this last Cubit which
which could have moved it around into
like into some other position in the in
the hbert space so this is one way that
air is going to
accumulate um you you also worry about
because we're measuring air is going can
accumulate because of the measurements
right so when you measure a state s uh
with projection Pi you get the state Pi
SI then
renormalized and so for example if um
if there's some small air and if this
measurement outcome occurs with probably
one half then the air is going to be
renormalized as well it's going to be
blown up by a factor of root2 and so
suddenly a small air a square of Epsilon
air has suddenly become a square of two
Epsilon error um and that's that's just
after one measurement and so if we're
playing little end games it's blowing up
exponentially
fast so that's that's obviously bad
too
um a second problem sort of when you
when you try to analyze it is that if if
you try to fix the first game it's going
to mess up the second game so what I
mean is um we know we know say we know
that game one has probably uh omega star
minus Epsilon of winning the first game
and say we also know that the probably
winning the second game uh condition on
the outcome of the first game is is also
omega star minus
Epsilon so now we can apply the theorem
we can apply the one shot rigidity
theorem to the first game so we know
that at the beginning of the first game
there's square of Epsilon close to
having the APR pair that they're
measuring in this Nic way so let's fix
it let's let's take the let's take the
actual Quantum state that they have and
replace it with the state that's square
of Epsilon close close to it the the the
epr pair let's put it put in exactly
that epr pair and let's fix it and then
and then then then the idea would be
after fixing the first game we can fix
the second game then fix the third game
fix the fourth game and that's how
that's how we're going to try try to
prove this theorem but that's no good I
mean because if we fix the first game by
by putting in epr pair we've we've
changed the state by square of Epsilon
which means now uh the probability of
winning this the second game is is is
going to be Omega stus Epsilon minus
root Epsilon so we've introduced some
new error into the second game and so
now that's fine I mean epsilon's
small I I guess um but you know root
epsilon's of course much bigger than
Epsilon and and so now when you try to
analyze the second game you only get
that the strategy is Epsilon to the
1/4th close to Ideal then you when you
fix that game the beginning of the third
game it's only going to be Epsilon to
the 1/8 close to Ideal and so again we
have a terrible blow up in in the
AA you continue for a one epon yeah
something like that
yeah
um so this this isn't going to work what
we're going to do instead is uh try to
work backwards we're going to try to fix
the last games first and move forward
forwards and then we're also going to
have to move sorry move backwards and
we're also have to go forwards uh as
well so so what we're going to do is um
we're going to fix the last games first
only the super operators the measurement
operators and then all the way back to
the beginning and then uh we're going to
fix the states after we fix the super
operators we're going to fix the states
going from forwards to the end and the
reason for that is you can't fix the
state of game n like in other words you
can't replace the state of the beginning
of game n by an ER Pense or something
because it could be that that state is
not the outcome of any measurement
it's like there could be no way of
getting to that state in the first n
minus one games so so you can't just you
can't CH throughout the throughout the
state and put in something that you
whatever you
like so that's that's one
issue um I think there's lots of issues
of this type when when you try to come
up with these proofs
um but let me let me sort of give give
you the intuition though and and how how
we actually get the proof
working and the idea really just has is
based on these two facts of epr pair so
the first one is just uh simple to
verify that if you have a 2 x two Matrix
M and you tensor with the identity apply
to this Vector 0 0+ one one that's the
same as the identity tensor M transpose
on this Vector 0 0+ one one you can just
check that and what what that means
though is that anything that's done on
the first half of an epr pair Alice's
half of an epr pair can equivalently be
done on the Bob's half of an epr pair up
to a
transpose
operation the second fact is is that
quantum mechanics is local which means
that uh anything that Bob does can't
affect what Alice sees which which seems
to contradict this first fact but but
but it's it's true an expectation so in
other words anything that Bob does uh
then you average over his outcomes can't
affect what Al what Alice is see what
Alice sees because she just sees her
density Matrix the same density Matrix
independent of what Bob
do and so here's how we can use these
two facts to show that for example
here's how we can use these two facts to
show that the last Cubit the Cubit used
in game n is in tensor product of the
first Cubit used in game one and that'll
just give you an idea of how how we how
we show tensor product for all the
cubits and basically what happens is
when you play game one there was almost
an nepr pair there we measured it so
it's collapsed it's just like something
some classical State and now we play G
we play the middle games and then we
play the last game and the point is the
these middle games uh Alice's
superoperator could be pulled over to be
acting on Bob's
side after Bob's super operator for
those
games uh by by the first
fact and what that means is is that they
don't affect uh Alice's state in
expectation which means that this this
first Cubit which was collapsed so it's
it's like it's like C zero or something
after these intermediate games it's
still cat zero in expectation so which
means it really is C close to C
zero and now so at the beginning of this
last game the first Cubit is still C
zero and we need an epr pair here
something close to an epr pair so it
can't overlap that state C zero because
you know C zero has is is not entangled
with something and we need we need a lot
of entanglement to play this game and so
that that that argument imp implies that
this last game really is is has to be in
tensor product with the first game
there's no overlap despite all these
weird arguments that air is going to
accumulate dly exponentially
fast
um actually uh the tensor product
structure is completely explicit it's
it's even it's even nicer than that um
we can construct uh the tensor product
structure we can see what it is what it
has to be and so let me let me briefly
show show you how that works too and so
um
yeah doesn't this apply
just what what was the what was the need
to go through the middle
guys uh I mean you were just you're
interested in seeing that the last one
is unentangled from the first one but
can't we just sort of build up each one
from the next I mean from the sets that
we had before think this argument that
the second is unentangled from the first
and the third is no well if you try to
do that I mean the error is I I I think
you'd have the same problem I mentioned
at first because all these kinds of
statements only hold approximately and
the errors would accumulate too quickly
so
that's if you just try to show the
second cu's intensive product so it's
approximately intensive product the
third Cube It's approxim intenser
product the areas would just blow up
yeah related this seems to establish
something that is like pairwise between
game one and G rather than the entire
state of all n Bits oh no that's that's
just because of I'm trying to simplify
things
yeah why doesn't effect one suffer from
the er sorry why doesn't Fact one suffer
from the same
errors oh it yeah it will um so because
we don't exactly have an epr State the
first fact will only hold up to like
square of Epsilon which means that when
we pull these operators over oops when
we when we pull these operators over the
other side we're going to lose a factor
of um n minus 2 Time Square of Epsilon
um because when you pull the operators
over those those errors will will will
accumulate but that's fine if you're not
if you're not too concerned about
efficiency it's
fine
okay
um so so so here's here's sort of how we
can here we determine exactly what the
tensor product structure is and it's
it's it's totally cheating so so what I
do is um we play the first game so we
measure this cubid so it's collapsed to
either you know K zero kep one kep plus
or kep minus whatever the measurement
outcome was at some classical State
now and then what I'm going to do is I'm
going to add an enill Cubit just a fresh
Cubit cat zero this is my isometry so
I'm embedding the space in a higher
dimensional Space by adding adding this
C
zero then I'm going to swap it with with
the cuid that was used in game one just
swap those two
positions uh and now I'm going to keep
on playing the rest of the games games
two through in on this part of the hrid
space you see for free uh I mean sort of
by definition now games two through n
are in tensor product with with this
cuit here with the Cubit used in game
one and they can't overlap that cuid
because we swapped it out into a fresh
position there's there's no overlap with
it anymore so so so I've defined this
this this strategy and it is intenser
product um every Cubit is intenser
product um with the Cubit used in game
one and of course we can generalize we
can we can extend this to make sure that
every Cubit is is intenser product game
one game two game three game four this
this
first um oh so sorry so so actually to
make that work I I I also need to uh if
if we just swap these two cubits then
this is SK zero whereas it should have
been X1 so I'll also as part of the
isometry I'll just rotate it into in
X1
okay so this this the defines some
tensor product strategy the problem is
it's not the same as the as the actual
strategy it's just a random strategy I
came up with that that is int that where
the cubits measured are intenser product
and so we need to argue that this
strategy is really close to the ideal
strategy and it's really just sort of a
commutative diagram like this so I want
to say that um if you play game one and
then you apply this weird isometry where
you add an enilla swap the cubits rotate
the enilla and then play games 2 through
N I want to say that's the same as
playing game one playing games two
through n and then and then applying
this isometry adding K zero swapping the
two cubits and rotating it
rotating so that's that's a that's a
that's completely formally what we're
trying to
prove and it's quite simple to see how
how it works so on on the right I have
the actual Strate sorry the tensor
product strategy so when you when you
play games two through n uh you mess up
this cuit
potentially
you you mess up this this cubid here
potentially this is the first game's
cuid um and and so it's it's no longer
kx1 it could be something different it
could have could have been messed up but
but here this is still X1 because
nothing in games two through and use it
uses in silic cubid whereas in the
actual
strategy
um games two through and mess up this
first Cubit this is the cubit that's
used in the game
one uh and then you apply the isometry
it swaps that out out to
here and you rotate in a fresh Ancilla
into this
position and so we want to show that
these two the left picture and the right
picture are the same so the tensor
product strategy is the same as as the
actual strategy up to this isometry and
so that's that's the same essentially as
showing that you know uh this Cubit that
that started out X1 really stays
X1 these to be the same and these should
be the same and then then the left
picture is the same as right picture the
tensor product strategy is the same as
the ideal
strategy does it come with some uh error
as well with the
swapping um any what do you mean there's
the that we're comparing these two
pictures with the swapping in the an
does it come with some like are the two
pictures exactly identical or they
actually are different no I mean they
really are different because um uh this
state here that I say used to be X1 it's
it's not X1 it really could have changed
a bit and will it would have changed a
bit I would that cumulate also linearly
in the number of cubits in the yeah okay
so what's what's the difference in this
analysis about the err
accumulation because initially the error
accumulate well here's only here here
the error is is only ACC accumulating
linearly it's not accumulating
exponentially or
anything
I mean actually you have to see how the
argument worked to see that but
um this is sort of the setup to that
that that argument though
yeah okay so so that's that's sort of
how how how how the proof Works um we we
it really boils down just to showing
that once you measure a cubit it
collapses that Cubit into a classical
State and it stays collapsed from from
that on nobody nobody else can mess it
up very
much um
I think I'll skip over this this just
gives you u a little bit
more uh technical details of how the
theorem Works what what I've said so far
is that this the the strategies of Alice
and Bob are together close to Ideal
meaning that they're they're when you
apply both super operators together um
it's close to when you apply both the
ideal super operators together but for
the applications I want something
stronger I want to say that even if Bob
doesn't play any chsh games at all even
if even if only Alys is playing the chsh
games her strategies are close to aideal
on on their
own this this will be very important for
any
applications uh so we want them to be
separately close to IDE deal
um and and I don't think I have time to
explain this but it's it's really just
um a a two-line proof in this example um
to show how to starting with joint
jointly ideal strategy you can pull out
that you have separately ideal
strategies
I think I'll skip over the applications
too uh because um talked about a lot of
them um for example
dqd or or this delegated computations
idea but instead I think maybe the most
interesting thing for for a workshop
kind of setting is to say something
about some of the open questions so so
so one of the open questions is about
parallel composition of of um of the
chsh games do you still have the same
kinds of
theorems um another another question
that that that that we got heard from
last time too is what happens if you
have other games um besides the chsh
game potentially every game is is
locally potentially every game in which
the quantum value is above the classical
value uh it's locally rigid I don't
think we have any counter
examples
um but we don't know and and I mean the
reason for understanding that I think is
uh partly just hopefully that you you
can get a nicer proof to this kind of
theorem because it's kind of a
um a second the a second a third open
question that I think is interesting is
to try to make this kind of uh test much
more
efficient um and
so I I've said that we have this
polinomial we have various polinomial
blowups so in theory it's efficient but
it's it's quite bad we'd like to be able
to show that even if you win even if you
have a constant error rate then since
similar kinds of theorems should hold so
say you win with probably 84% so that's
1% off from optimal
uh can you still come up with a similar
kind of theorem so for example you can
conjecture that uh say you play little n
chsh games sequentially or parallell uh
and there's a high probability of
winning 84 84% fraction of them is it
true that they must share roughly in epr
pairs in order to do this and measure
them in some in some very nice one at a
time tensor product
way could be true I don't know um you
want to
use yeah I mean that's one idea use use
f tolerance where are you um hi yeah
yeah you use some sort of f tolerance
idea or or maybe try to put these kinds
of theorems on top of themselves
um I don't know it's like a very it's a
much more a stronger monogamy statements
what you need to be able to show I don't
know um I think there's a it could be
true I think it's
interesting um
uh other questions what what if you
allow communication between rounds so
for example here I'm saying you play
these and n chsh games one after the
next um but they can't talk to each
other and this is a problem for
applications like um device independent
qu key distribution because in most uh
qkd setups you generate the entanglement
dynamically right you generate one APR
pair you measure it you generate another
APR pair you measure it and so on like
that like that and this this kind of
proof doesn't allow analyzing that kind
of setup we need all the epr pairs all
the entanglement to be present at the
very beginning of the day and then you
say these devices don't talk to each
other from then
on to so you can apply these theorems
and so what one question you could ask
is um uh is there still a tensor product
structure can can you still use this
structure to get device independent qkd
um even if youve communication between
rounds if there's Communication in a
round then nothing you can't say
anything
and I guess the last open questions is
just uh to come up with more more
applications for example in Randomness
extraction or
amplification um or or delegated
computation I'll talk about that on stre
all right thank
you so I guess this is a question mainly
about the applications of cryptography
to KY
um normally in 2kd we like to say the
Epper will be happy to get caught with
50% probability if that means he can
break you know the whole key um whereas
your assumption seems to be that Eve is
taking some strategy which she's almost
certain not to get
caught yeah I
see
uh I mean intuitively all you know the
the the statement some version of the at
least the qkd could still work right
because no I feel like you can get
around this just with classical St
statistics by repeating it enough times
or something you know no because you can
always you can always say well I'm going
to do some kind of superp position of
you know doing different kinds of
attacks and some of those attacks will
get caught and some of those attacks
won't get caught and then you have to
then you have to show that somehow
there's no interference between these
that it lets her Che better by doing
that yeah but I I think
uh like you don't have to worry about
sus you just worry about CL about well
yeah you have to worry about some
combinations of attacks I agree but I
uh I think when you break it up
blockwise you you can still say things
like if there's a 50% probability of of
cheating the whole protocol like with
with many
blocks um
then
let me say it another way if if if
there's the converse would be if you if
there's a a what is
it if there's a small probability of
cheating if there's twoo large a
probability of cheating in one of the
blocks then
um you you can't cheat too much in in
the full game but look so so so again he
can do so this is this is yeah not a a
real attack but it's a counter example
to the sort of statement that you're
trying to make which is you can say 50%
of the time I will do honest behavior
and do exactly what I'm supposed to 50%
of the time I'll just do something crazy
and cheat on all the
blocks no but no but see then then that
that's fine because then this this block
this block thing does work in that case
because then you could just say pick a
random block and you
win so pick a random block and in that
random block they had uh they had to
have had a high probability of
winning no that's but you don't right
because in every block you have a 50%
chance of getting caught and a 50%
chance of not getting caught you need to
condition so yeah so what you want is a
some sort of statement like conditioned
on her not getting caught then but I
don't know what goes after the
then okay anyway yeah yeah yeah
understand what you're saying
yeah so just just some wild speculation
here so you've kind of used the specific
properties of this setup to kind of
avoid this exponential blow up and error
now now this is reminiscent of this
problem in like State generation so for
example if you want to come up with a
qma protocol for the graph
nonisomorphism problem one way to do
that would be to generate a uniform
superposition of all the permutations of
a graph uh and you can try and construct
such a superposition iteratively but the
problem is you get this exponential blow
up in your error so you know by the time
you get there your St should be not the
right one and I'm just wondering if you
could maybe somehow use some ideas here
to kind of avoid this exponential blob
an error this is all very handwavy of
course but you know I don't know what
you what further assumptions you need in
order to get that but I'm just wondering
if there is a potential application to
that problem I don't know I haven't
thought about that I mean you ask sort
of how how particular are are our
methods to this kind of um
situation and um like it seems like they
are and you know in all likelihood you
can't they don't transfer easily but
like like we use all over the place
pulling operations from one side to the
other side back and forth yeah because
you have epr States but I wonder if you
can you know ask aover to send you a
bunch of epr states and test them in
some way I don't know way I don't know
yeah um just
wondering there are any connections with
the another aspect of uh testing unknown
h space is a dimension like independent
way of testing Dimension but there they
kind of establish a lower bound on the
dimension by violation of some bels
inequality whereas here seems like you
have an amp bound because you don't
restrict in the serum restrict the
dimension of the h space uh but they use
General PMS whereas you only assume
projecting Marin so do you think there's
a connection here can make some kind of
Dimension statement
um uh based on the serum no I I think
actually they're probably pretty similar
I'm not sure exactly what you mean but I
think they're very similar these kinds
of statements like we're showing that
the dimension really is at least lower
bounded by two to the N or
something um that's probably what the
kind of thing they try to show
too yeah you have some on why when you
have a
game
no I mean I don't have it I I just
guessed I think it's because I don't
know why I just well I don't know I
think Quantum is kind of rounded so
there's a
local yeah it's an interesting
question